[Music]
hello and welcome to episode number 67
of the weekly daily Google cloud
platform podcast it is day three here
google cloud next and I am Francis
convoy and as always I'm here with my
colleague with my dear colored today
mark modèle hey Mark how are you doing
I'm good it's my birthday oh all I said
I was gonna say it before he said it
okay so yeah happy birthday mike from me
and all the people that we interviewed
and there's actually a lot of people
that came just to say happy birthday and
I'm gonna say that if you're listening
to this episode you should definitely
tweet at neurotic and say happy birthday
neurotic ah yeah although that he
appreciates dogs so you can take
pictures of like you dogs he'll be happy
actually I will but that's great I know
today we we are very lucky to get to
interview three amazing people from
google cloud two of them working for
marketing that's the first thing that
we're gonna have and we're gonna be
talking about something pre amazing if
you've watched the keynote you might
have noticed that first was wearing some
really cool earring so at least we know
that he is always earth because he has
the chip he is the real earth exactly
we're gonna learn what that chip what
that earring is and what the back story
behind it is a very interesting one yep
and and after that we'll be talking two
mouths word who is an all-around great
guy he's been doing cloud stuff for for
a long time and I'm just excited to talk
to him nobody's the topic so yeah miles
is fantastic he's the global head of
solutions at Google Cloud and always has
fantastic stories about customers and
engagements that he's head across the
platform so we get to talk to maths
board later on but for now let's go talk
about Earth's earring with our friends
for marketing cool let's do that we're
now joined by two very very important
people here at club next very impor
we have cornelius village and neil
Mueller how are you both doing awesome
well great now but I know how important
it so for everybody else that that's not
know how important you why didn't you
tell us a little bit well you are what
do you do a Google so I'm Cornelius
Willis and I take her product marketing
for Google cloud platform which means I
get to work with amazing people like
Neil so what about your nail my name is
Neil and I work on infrastructure
product marketing at gcp which means
like get to work with Cornelius cool so
we have you here specifically for
something that happened during the
keynote ship yeah the chip which was
pretty amazing if you have not seen if
you listen to the podcast and you have
not seen the keynote i recommend go I am
watch it at some point earth I'm gonna
try to say his name I think it's always
a test there's wholesome mirage poplar
help slit yes it's I never I'm gonna go
with Earth's for now so hers showed that
he was wearing an earring that was a
chip that that's authentication for
stuff and machines in the cloud what is
that thing so that is the Titan
authentication ship that goes on a whole
bunch of Google hardware essentially
every piece of hardware and Google's
infrastructure can be individual
identified in any service using it
usually authenticates to that hardware
and the Titan ship is one of the ways we
accomplish that and we are so excited to
be able to actually reveal that I mean
if we think about the product markings
job for Google cloud platform its to
convince leadership to progressively
expose more and more Google innovation
even if we're a little uncomfortable
with it yeah so this is a great example
of when we were actually able to throw
back the kimono on something it's really
interesting and is is really different
from what other other cloud platforms
provide yeah I like the the jerk that
ours did which was a since we have the
Titan chip this is an authentic Google
cloud platform like it's okay yeah
google that platform keynote like we
know for sure that it's him well the
thing too is I was a little worried when
you removed it from his ear because then
he was no longer in a trusted good
statement
down with happy to you know me well yeah
right that's it yes has been deactivated
well I mean because everything in the
environment is untrusted until proven
trusted buried so yeah let's let's talk
about the chip what exactly does the
chip do let's take a step back before we
start getting into the nerdery of this
security microchips I'm just really
excited by the notary on analogy so I
bet there's more people in the audience
that have seen the movie inception then
understand what a microbes the security
microprocessor is which is what
tightness so if you've seen the movie
inception and if you have not you should
go what you see a crescent will be about
you kind of have to see that in order to
if you haven't seen you have to stop Liz
from the podcaster probably right I'd
say so yeah yeah so inception is all
about this thing in philosophy called in
simulation theory and it's the
disconnection and the concern about
there being a disconnection between your
perception of reality and reality itself
that you might actually be living inside
of somebody else's dream somebody else's
Sim City and it's not actually your own
little life that's exactly the concern
that Google has with regard to our
hardware and our software we want to
make sure that the relationship between
our hardware and our software comes up
in a way that we consider trusted and
that's why we have a security
microprocessor that we call tighten that
authenticates this relationship every
time we push a new piece of BIOS which
is software located on the hardware
Titan authenticates that installation
and every single time that Hardware
boots up some software that we've given
it it authenticates that Buddha and it
allows us to have like Cornelia said
authenticated service to service level
communication between our hardware
software and also within our software in
our software it's really similar in
theory to the stuff that we also have in
our security keys that every Googler has
on their computer insofar as we believe
at Google that everything should have an
identity our Hardware has identity our
software has identity we live in a
constantly state that we consider always
untrusted and we verify the identity of
everything all of the time and that way
if anything in our infrastructure is
deemed
road we can very quickly d identify it
and then carry on with business so I'm
wondering does that mean that every
single one of those little chips has
some secret built-in in there like basic
like Cuba keys did something that
basically at any point you can decide
which one is the one is like that is not
a good one and you just stop trusting
the machine or whatever piece of
hardware you have yeah so how do you
know that the Titan itself is the real
type yeah like cuz that you have many of
them right so would later write it
startles all the way down you can refuse
each individual Titan ship with the
unique identifier and this doesn't mean
the writing that was on the top although
we did remove that and when we when we
gave it to us and let it make an earring
out of it wasn't good on the jewelry
anyway it didn't it's not a style we
were eating with it with a diamond stud
yeah that's right so we've had that
little numbers now the fusing happens
inside the read-only memory of the chip
itself and it's done in such a way it's
done sequentially so that we can tell
that it's a Titan ship that's in our
inventory sequence and it's it's done
and theoretically is only being able to
be written once and can't be changed
within the chip during its shipment are
the chips entire lifetime so you know
that that is the real McCoy and just to
be clear though we make the chips right
yeah like I mean a lot of our stuff we
control the design in the manufacture of
that so that we are able to ensure to
the greatest to be possible has not been
tampered with on roof this is one of the
big differentiators of our cloud versus
every other cloud that I've been able to
learn anything about there are other
folks that run data centers and other
clouds as well and they can buy servers
that have security micro processors on
them the majority of those that I've
talked to don't use those security micro
processors in fact no cloud that I've
been able to talk to uses their security
micro processors that are given to them
by other other vendors not only do we
use those but we created our own because
it's not our Jam to not understand fully
the supply chain yeah and so we purpose
build our servers and our chips and our
security micro processors and our racks
and our network controllers as you saw
in the picture when urges up on stage we
want to fully understand the supply
chain so that we can guarantee
provenance over the security of our club
so it's not just identity that we're
trying to authenticate but also heritage
where did that thing come from prod nuts
provenance yeah it sounds like it's like
the whole thing to from buy us all the
way through the software is this doing
the thing we think it's meant to be
doing and if it's not and perpetually
challenge that across the entire system
so to go back a little bit and get a
little bit away from the gig nest area
well we will be back there in a minute
and know who had the idea of saying oh
let's put a jib on versus here so or
seven saw the little chips and you don't
kneel first of all like somehow convince
someone to give him some of these trips
and so you know Neil is a very robust
guy so I don't know what happened to
that person thank God we got the chips
and so Neil showed them doors and their
least you're very cute little things and
worse if ooh that could be an arid and
then he looked at me a few minutes later
to no don't don't do that no don't do it
anyway was going and Neil I mean time
had gone off and found what I don't know
where you found earrings like did you go
to you know one of our product managers
my I knew of a craft store nearby and
i'll sit there now the best things
happen so you got both the earring posts
and the superglue at the same store same
place yeah very useful very efficient
and so he came back with the studs and
you know convinced him that it would be
something that would really get his
picture in a lot of places and could
potentially glue his ear together with
superglue yeah and the thing that I
think we were excited about is figuring
out how to actually map this down into
or his own sort of you know immune
system so it's just the same way we have
an immune system for our cloud you know
maybe yeah figure out how to make that
connection I'm a little sad actually I
tried to put it through my ear I had my
ear pierced when I was like 15 or so and
in the hole slightly closed ever so I
couldn't put it in properly and then I
was like well maybe is cuz you're not
your authenticator ball there it no no
you know what maybe everyone to press
I'm not
I'm not Aries and it's going well know
who you are so we're not doing this
thing right yeah so going back to the
gig nazariya yeah I'm curious so this is
a very useful thing to have right the
fact that you're able to authenticate a
piece of hardware it is amazing for us
Google but it might also be amazing for
all the people everywhere in the world
right is this something that is offered
as a service or it's just like a
security layer that is internal to
Google so right now we're the only cloud
that we know of that's currently using a
security microprocessor not only are we
the only one using one period but we're
the only one that has purpose built one
if we were to make this this ship
addressable for customers configurable
for customers we would be the first
cloud to do so we don't currently do
that okay that's fair enough I think
this is also super interesting right the
whole question of the cloud and this
often comes up where it's like hey is
the cloud secure right we get that sort
of thing like oh god we can't prove
things to do the cloud this is one of
those great examples of oh my gosh what
did Eric Schmidt day on stage give us
like he's so Joe cloud now yeah and
don't don't try to do this yourself it's
a waste of your money yeah we've been
able to pay it seems like this is sort
of thing where you're like is this the
type of security you would do yourself
if you're building stuff on your own
like data centers your own networks how
much effort do you want to put in
yourself like I mean this must have been
a huge investment to make this nation
well in a huge investment not only in
money but in time yeah research many
many many years of building out the
layered architecture that it hasn't
stopped continue to do that so you might
be curious what goes into a security
microprocessor like Titan so within
Titan are three things a random number
generator a crypto engine and a
monotonic counter so I have those three
the the one that I really didn't
understand until I googled it was
monotonic counter and now that I learned
what it means I'm super excited to share
so a monotonic counter is essentially
something that protects against replay
attacks in addition to other other
threat vectors and it ensures that
account goes forward and never backward
you know it's a tool within logs to make
tamper evident because if you were ever
to remove a
against hope that never happened that
person never came here it would be
obvious because it would go from two to
four to five it'd be obvious that you'd
remove something and if you tried to
insert something and say something
happen when it actually didn't the
monotonic counter would would be proof
positive that it had not occurred so
those are three things inside a secure
microprocessor cool so we said what goes
inside of Titan talked about what he's
used for where does it actually go other
than on ears yeah sure so the position
is very important for this particular
product it needs to sit between ROM and
RAM in order to provide a signature
validation of the first 8 kilobits of
installation of a bios for example or
the boot up of any other pieces of
hardware and once it validates the first
aid kilobits kilobytes of installation
it lets you install the rest of the bios
and n every machine boot cool so uh
Wallace question uh is this something
we're gonna start creating a fashion
line on it is our people starting to use
it do you see people amount of you
walking walking around with chips on
their heads which would not surprise me
to be honest now so yeah we're gonna be
making these but the Titan ship is
comprised of an outer case and an inner
an inner microprocessor we're removing
the inner microprocessor and then we're
going to be attaching the exterior cake
to cufflinks earrings and tie clips and
will be he'll see them I'm so in you'll
sell to give more to that see them at
the next nexts
I am I am so in there's an amazing fun
excellent well I think that's about it
is there anything else either of you
would like to add or anything that has
been mentioned that you think is
important thank you to you guys for
doing this podcast day in day out the
tireless work and creativity that you
provide and thanks to our listeners for
being on Google cloud platform being
interested in what we're doing thank you
for taking the time to come talk to us
today so tighten is super super cool
thanks to create a seal for coming by
and giving us a good long chat about
that and thanks for bringing one of them
may was really cool to play with it we
got to touch one so cool um but why
don't we head on over and talk to our
dear friend miles whose effervescent
energy brings everything to life sounds
good LEDs of that amazingly excited and
delighted to be joined by Miles Ward
global head of solutions at Google cloud
thank you so much for joining us miles
thank you I'm just super excited to be
here what an incredible week it's it's
an amazing pleasure for me to have you
here I used to listen to your voice long
time ago on that a u.s. podcast long
time ago that's exactly how it is
amazing to have you here at the gcb
podcast now it's it's it's just you know
the changing of the seasons yeah from
the sort of cold winter of one cloud to
the bright spring of another ooh I like
the metaphor such a beautiful and
poetical way of putting it yeah before
we talk to you about next and stuff can
you tell us a bit about what you do at
Google absolutely so we have customers
that's the definitely okay lifeblood of
any cloud write it like cloud
technologies incredible stuff but it
really doesn't do anything until it
meets the road with customer demand and
actual usage in the field so my team
engages with customers as they've gone
through working with our salespeople are
customer engineers that are kind of the
first line of technical defense and then
they have escalation points like folks
that are in specialist roles and in
sales but when everybody gives up when
everybody goes that's too technical and
scary and I'm not sure how we would
build
at the solutions architecture team is
the top point of escalation air so I run
that team globally you are also the team
that is responsible for all the amazing
white papers that we have available
right yeah it's we think of it as a very
virtuous cycle right we go out to
customers that all of our folks have
told us we don't know how to do this we
try to figure out how to do it if we're
successful and we aren't always but most
of the time we are if we can figure out
how to make something work we write it
down because we are easily bored it's
four times in a row so we read it that
we published it that's all the material
that's at cloud cool calm / solutions
and that stuff our best practices or
step-by-step instructions on how to move
an application to the cloud or how to
back up an application or how to build
it for scale or setup for IOT or do work
in media and entertainment oil and gas
and all over the place so that kind of
guidance one gets us out of doing the
same thing twice but helps us stay
focused on what's next for customers and
also now that no one is listening help
us helps us here at the podcast because
we might have been used some of those
solutions as the main script for our I
podcast episode so thank you very much
for those ones hey we are you're
definitely yeah then they show up were
like oh good cool thing of the week well
it's it's one of the things that's
exciting for me right I mean any team
has to grow you can't just like install
a 200 Pearson team out of thin air so
we've been growing very rapidly and what
it allows us to do is ship more of this
stuff right so we've gone from you know
12 of them two years ago to 70 of them
while our took Wow I think we're going
to take a goal for a hundred of them
getting shipped this year that is crazy
on top of that so it's really it's and
we watch like I can see the statistics
of visitors coming in and downloading
this material and I can see they go over
and we see new accounts that follow
these patterns that's that's real
business growing on top of us and and
reduced risk right like I hate doing
stuff from scratch if I don't know what
is that I mean when I'm not like
involved in some kind of creative
process if I'm just trying to get
something done and there aren't
instructions that super obnoxious
and so when we talk to customers they
every single one says I just want you to
tell me how I'm supposed to do it so
we're trying to do that yeah and it's so
much better to learn from the mistakes
of others that that's right doing
yourself that's right and we I think we
have an environment that that really
radical ed risks that kind of
experimentation I think it's a fun place
to build new things and to try stuff out
but I think some people have have a
certain amount of budget and a certain
amount of time and focus for that kind
of experimentation yeah and then the
rest of the time is spent on the
obnoxious stuff that should just work
we're trying to go through and
step-by-step walkthrough each of those
pieces and make it so that they just
work right like backing up a database is
not something that is a creative and
advanced expression of your life goes on
the weekend so much fun you know it
should probably have a manual yep yeah
now you obviously you speak to a lot of
customers and you've been here cloud
next how have the experiences for people
you've talked to bin like what has been
the response you've had to the venue in
the event so I mean I I think there's a
couple of phrases that have come out of
our keynotes and come out of some of our
big presentations that have had a really
big impact on the perspective from the
customers that I talked with I mean I
had I went to three different customer
dinners just last night did you eat
dinner three times well you know you can
have a lot of salad and everybody sort
of thinks that you're participating in
the fullness of the chow so what I heard
from customers was sort of three basic
things first was from the first keynote
seeing HSBC on stage that's an account
that I did a lot of work with I'm super
excited to see them take the stage
seeing how clearly for them that the
value of cloud was associated with the
speed with which they could do things
like what they're seeing in every one of
the examples and demonstrations is and
this stuff is fast it's not fast like
you know 100 million I office or
something like that it's fast like it
takes Evernote three months to move it
takes lush a month to move it takes
Ocado's six hours to rewrite their etl
right like these autistics are not
material to go wait a minute wait a
minute I'm planning and budgeting in the
back of my mind on like Netflix scales
where it's going to take seven years to
migrate if I can do this stuff in months
and steady
the economics are totally different the
value proposition is totally different
and that's as I go around enterprise to
enterprise even little startups that are
already implemented in other places they
say why I didn't realize that it was
that much faster that's that's a big
deal to me that really changes my
perspective so that's awesome that's
super awesome to see nice there's
something to be said there about like
the also the exponential growth that you
can have like Pokemon go Oh in niantic
yeah like so yeah talk about exponential
growth so I was at the gcp event they
didn't call him next yet 23 years ago oh
yeah I remember those 375 people there I
went to the one last year presented a
bunch built a bunch of stuff they're
built the treehouse over there for them
oh yeah they're 2600 people that came
through the door for that they're like
almost 14,000 people here it's crazy I
think that's it's 10x and then five XO
safe okay 53 x we're gonna have to put
in intermediary floors inside a Moscow
and be able to fit enough humans to
watch all the stuff that we're building
up I mean it's outrageous growth creates
grow it is pretty amazing also seeing
all the number of all the partners that
we have all around it is amazing yeah
yeah yeah even just walking through the
startup space there's like 10 15 of them
in there just all of them doing each
individual cool things so so what other
things have have you heard from
customers that were really excited about
like is what was there any specific
announcement or something like that that
they were like oh that thing was amazing
so I was surprised it you know I know
the degree to which we hold it as as
sort of its own unique you know class of
thing but the messaging around spanner
has landed yeah right and when I talk to
customers they go look man I read that
paper five years ago I know that you
guys have the crown jewels hiding
someplace I know that that's the one we
we are diving in figuring it out and I'm
watching on the inside as we work with
customers and look at the metrics I mean
the growth on spanner adoption in weeks
stupefying right like we're I've got
engineers on the SRT team changing
trajectory of focus to deploy more and
more infrastructure into the span or
hosting just to be able to keep pace
with demand and and as I customers are
talking about it they look at and I
think they got the message upfront about
the idea of yeah I can do globally
consistent transactions I can make it so
that when I write something on one side
of the planet on the other side of the
planet I'm not messed up and out of sync
but I don't think they really realized
that that came along with super super
fast super super big right like the
simpler message of yep millions of I ops
is okay yep doing it at gazillions
abides you can put terabytes in there as
fine bet abides in there is what Eric
they're like I get both okay wait a
minute how am I what like it seems very
surprising to them so it's cool that
we've been able to you know really
hammer on both of those messages and I'm
seeing businesses saying like I it's
weird I you're right I I don't like my
oracle and I'm not super stoked about my
ma's equal all of those are sort of a
pain in the neck like maybe I should try
this out so what's your point of view on
the fact that well spanner a steel beta
does that mean that people are not using
it it seems like it's pretty much the
other way around no i mean so I mean in
my experience what I've seen you have to
imagine there's there's a range of
products that are being built by Google
cloud platform that are being built for
cloud right now as we speak built from
scratch right the DLP API is not that
way we take a service from g sweet and
we externalize it as a dedicated service
that customers can use right spanner is
an example that's more that way where we
have a running production system
handling
leans and millions of transactions a
second serving hundreds of Google
businesses it is highly mature in its
operations model our SLS are well
defined who have a clear standard of
service there the new part is that we're
charging for it to this little building
components got to get slapped on you got
to have an API that's externalize that
you can slap on and we need to test
those to the same level of rigor as the
core operations I think in database
world for me the big risk or the big
terror is losing data we're having data
corrupted and I think those are the
places where the new layers that are
part of spanner to make it something
that can be a public service they just
don't affect that part at all so I see
customers able to do that calculus and
say well yeah let's let's dive in let's
figure that out since you're on the
customer side and now I'm just curious
that you seeing customers as they jump
in on the beta being able to kind of
provide feedback and push the direction
of like where the product goes yeah so I
had a great conversation on Twitter
yesterday the one of the parts of the
design of the product in order to be
able to meet the the tight SLS that it's
designed for to be able to deliver the
kind of transactional consistency it's
not multi-tenant so we we asked you to
build individual nodes which we call on
our side and like any good relational
structure that's that's replicated your
your real default there is to deploy
three nodes so the minimum cost to run
it 24 7 with those three base nodes
putting lots of gigabytes of data in
there it's about 2,000 bucks a month and
so when I talk to developers they say
look look look when I'm in prod I'm
gonna give you two hundred thousand
dollars a month because I'm gonna wander
in this at the size of the moon but
right now I want to mess around on my
laptop and I want to mess it up around
in a way that I know is compatible with
the primary thing or fine if it's
impossible to put on my laptop give me
something that I can run on a micro or
whatever so that so that it's at a price
point that's compatible and I know our
product managers they made under the
houses of the market and they're looking
what what technology they have available
I think we were really eager to take
what we know of as the exact best
practice for a product that already has
a reputation years before it's launched
and make sure that that prod
behaves exactly the way customers have
dreamed about for years now they've got
their hands on the real deal I think
it's the feedback that I've heard is
clear enough that it's obvious to me
that will go through and do the work to
create something that's designed for
developer consumption so that the
experimentation can happen without
costing a couple grand nice is there
anything else that you think our
audience would like to know like any any
anecdote anything that might have
happened backstage that you'd like to
share sure sure so i'll tell you one
that that's that's funny so so Chris
cells is the product manager building on
the stuff yet windows ringing he's the
guy who did the car crash on stage with
the Hot Wheels how I write like that i
think is hysterical right ladies we need
to do this sort of at a different scale
and we brings out these car actually
makes a crash noise everything so what
he told me was that you know you really
had to kind of go through and think hard
about you know which Hot Wheels would he
bring on stage you know like these are
gonna be famous hot wheel cars yeah
that's better right like it you know
they're gonna it takes a video
sightseeing cycle so you started had to
pick through his kids box and find just
the two coolest trucks that he had I I
think that we have amazing speakers and
they do the weirdest things we also saw
this morning just in back with with a
durian yeah yeah taking it stage just
cause I don't know what's happened there
but yeah that is pretty amazing
unbelievable alright miles will thanks
for taking the time come hang out with
us the podcast we really appreciate you
telling the stories and amen you ever
want to come back again we've more the
plated have you hey you guys are doing
outrageously great work I work every day
and take benefit from the awareness that
you create so I super appreciate it and
I'd love to come back in exchange next
time you come you need to play the tuba
you gave it to but us oh yeah oh yeah
there's backstory there
fantastic thank you so much thanks Jed
pipe so thanks again miles for such an
interesting conversation I've met him
long time ago like first time I heard
his name was long time ago now on the
AWS podcast last time I saw him was
somewhere in Japan he was giving talks
all around the world his super cool guy
so thanks so much for taking the time to
talk to us it is sad but it's over this
is the end this is the end well least
till next week yeah till next week this
is the end of cloud next 2017 it was an
amazing conference yeah and we didn't
want to finish the episode at the fourth
episode in this week without saying a
huge thanks to our dear editors yep
Shawn James thank you so much for
putting up with this during daily
episodes editing all a podcast amazing
yeah to everyone who's listening huge
thanks to them because they do an
amazing amazing job yeah especially
because you can maybe you cannot tell
but bringing Freddie be tired so we
actually keep on messing it up and they
need to edit it up back to making it
sound almost normal so thank you thank
you so much and princess thank you to
you for being so wonderful here as well
today thank you Mark for being here on
your birthday it happy birthday yes and
thanks to everyone who came past the
booth said hello grab some stickers grab
some t-shirts even just wounded up and
which is like hey we love the podcast
hey was awesome hey thank you so so much
we really felt the love ya and thanks to
everyone who listens and talk to you all
next week see you all next week
you